[Music]
all right people we are live on the
YouTube I haven't done one of these in a
while just me and you human-to-human
through the tubes of the Internet I'm
very excited today we cracked 600,000
subscribers overnight I suspect
according to our internal metrics that
happen at about 2:00 a.m. Pacific time
and and it's pretty awesome this last
hundred thousand came faster than any
hundred thousand before that the five
hundred thousand mark came faster than
any hundred thousand before that and so
on we've really just grown tremendously
thanks to you guys and and it's pretty
awesome and there's so much good stuff
happening right now with the show with
the conversations we're having with all
these new interesting alliances you know
I said at the beginning of the year the
2018 is going to be the year of unusual
alliances I think there's a ton of
evidence for that already so I'm just
feeling very good about everything
that's going on we shot two shows
already today so I've already done two
both of them we're about an hour and a
half actually interviews today I'm one
of them I'm gonna leave as a as a
surprise although I am gonna tip you
guys off to some upcoming things and
then one of them I'll tell you about in
just a moment because we are expanding
some things we're doing some new new
little bonus things and all sorts of
cool stuff but anyway so in honor of
600,000 subscribers I thought we'd do in
a QA and I'll share some thoughts with
you and all that good stuff you want to
just say anything to me now is your
chance so of course if you are a member
on patreon you get the special benefits
that only a patron gets which is you'll
be bumped up to the top of the line so
if you have any questions you can just
ask in the patreon feed that goes
directly to David and Amira otherwise
you can jump in on super chat and if you
throw a couple bucks or whatever it is
the more you give I guess basically the
easier it is for us to see it and track
it and I have an iPad a fancy iPad from
this little startup company called Apple
and the questions get directly sent to
me so it comes from you and somehow
magically ends up right here in front of
me and we'll do we'll do it for about an
hour
emma is in studio if you're following on
Twitter you saw we
I believe the only interview show in the
world that has a pet bed on set and a
pet in it at this very moment so Emma's
right over there
and yeah there's a lot of cool stuff
going on I'm really feeling good about
things I know if you just listen to most
of the people especially in mainstream
news cable news everyone's hysterical
everything's crumbling everything is
horrible Trump ah it's like I actually
think there's a lot of cool stuff
happening right now and I'm very psyched
so let me just give you a couple couple
little things that are upcoming and then
we'll jump into some of this I see stuff
rolling in already so that's great so
first off one of the interviews I did
today will be aired in February so
during president's week which is
February 17th I believe that to the
Monday we are doing five shows in five
days with five different professors
about five different presidents former
presidents and I don't want to tell you
all the presidents but I interviewed a
professor today all about this Abraham
Lincoln fella and we got into the good
the bad the the nitty-gritty of all of
it we've shot two of those already but
that'll be just a great week and I want
to do more of that kind of thing where
we give you a little historical context
what I'm trying to do with all of these
interviews is not only learn the history
about some of these presidents but also
how we can view them through a 20-18
lens what would they be electable or
popular or interested in politics in
2018 you know and some of that's
obviously you know a little bit of
conjecture and you have to kind of well
it's up to the person sitting across
from me to tell me what they think but
getting great scholars in here and just
doing five shows like that that's sort
of like we've done YouTube week in the
past and and we're going to try to do
more of that kind of thing one other
thing I want to tip you off to before we
jump into the QA is that I forget what
day it is but January 31st I guess
that's probably next Tuesday if I'm not
mistaken but someone who correct me
January 31st we will crash the internet
because on this very channel right here
we will have Jordan Peterson and Ben
Shapiro in studio so I'm incredibly
psyched about that I'm gonna try to do
this in a completely different way where
we're not going to just talk about sort
of the standard political stuff that
we're talking about I've got a couple
ideas that I think are really going to
be different than a lot of the things
that you're
these two guys obviously Jordan and Ben
are out there all the time they're both
on fire I love the fact that they've
caught fire I think there's some places
of agreement and disagreement that's
completely irrelevant I just love that
they've so caught in the zeitgeist of
what's happening right now obviously
Jordan in particular after that channel
for news thing which was just so beyond
ridiculous
which you know it's sort of interesting
I'm sure many of you saw this where the
the interviewer who was very unprepared
and I know what it's like to be an
interviewer she basically was trying to
imply that his right to free speech is
less than someone in this case a trans
person's right to be not offended and he
just dealt with it so beautifully and I
think it actually will be looked back
years from now as one of the seminal
moments in sort of what's happening with
the Free Speech Movement and with
liberalism and all of the stuff that
we're talking about all the time sort of
like the sam harris ben affleck gross
and racist thing was i think another one
of those that bubbled up into mainstream
was ben shapiro with piers morgan about
guns but occasionally this group of
people that Eric Weinstein has coined
the term intellectual dark web and I see
that kind of catching along that this
crew that you guys are watching online
and listening to and all that that this
crew is out there and we occasionally
we're bubbling into mainstream I don't
even think we need them anymore I get
all kinds of offers at this point I
don't really even want them but I think
it's cool that there's some sort of
interesting crossover stuff happening
right now and all right let's jump into
some questions holy schmoly they're
flying in super chat you are the most
truthful interviewer on YouTube not a
question but I appreciate it I do the
best I can
I tried well I don't lie to you and I
try not to you know fudge facts or I
tell you what I think and if I screw up
occasionally okay and as some of you
guys know there have been times where I
have screwed something up and we you
know we pre-tape we don't always go live
as we're going right now and my guys
will say to me after you know do you
want to get rid of that and I never do
because alright I'm human I screwed up
something there there's one thing I
don't even need to mention it to get the
trolls to start the feeding frenzy but
there's one thing that I really screwed
up on a factual thing which I did
address in the comments right down below
but we left it there and it's like
alright I'm human I'm human okay
will you have Glenn back on again
absolutely I really enjoyed that
conversation with Glenn when we had him
in here was it about a year ago already
Wow time flies
I think Glenn is a good guy he's had an
interesting kind of navigation of what
he is and where he is politically over
these last couple years as so much as
has kind of changed but certainly on the
libertarian stuff and the small
government stuff and your individual
liberty and to live your life as you see
fit Glenn and I certainly agree on a lot
of that stuff most of it and yeah I
think the blaze is actually doing a
profile piece on me they interviewed me
you know very leery of interviews at
this point or at this point when
BuzzFeed or any of these places reach
out to me I pretty much just ignore it
but a buzz feeI sorry a blaze writer
reached out to me seemed like a great
guy we did our due diligence I sat in
here with it for with him for a couple
hours and I think we're doing a photo
shoot and I sounds like they're gonna do
a fair spread on me but we shall see
would you or have you considered
inviting Penn Jillette I'd love to have
Penn Jillette we've had a couple back
and forth with him David maybe can let
me know where we're at with that big
time libertarian I briefly met him for a
split second when I spoke at the reason
rally in DC about a year and a half ago
I'd love to have him on Penn if you're
watching this let's do it man come on
now what are you doing over there
super chat hey Dave will you be having
Thomas Sola on your show at some point
yes I have his advance copy of his new
book which I think drops in about two
and a half weeks I have so many books
that people are upcoming guests you're
sending me I've got Steven Pinker's book
over here and a couple of others
we're just waiting to work out the all
the logistics with with dr. Sol
obviously he doesn't do a ton of
interviews at this point I believe he's
86 years old but probably the most
influential classical liberal thinker
sort of in the modern day or at least in
that certainly in that top tier that
goes without saying he's up at Stanford
so what we're gonna do for that is what
we did with I can't even say it but
we're gonna can't say that there's a
reason I can't say it just let it be but
we're gonna do an on-location shoot at
Stanford University with dr. Tsao and
I'll try to get some other people that
are in the San Francisco area because we
have to rent a studio I gotta fly my
guys up there and and hotels and all
that and that by the way is fully funded
by you guys that support us on patreon
because per video we certainly don't
make any of that real money back and so
you guys absolutely enable us to do that
by the way speaking of monetization
which I'm happy to talk about if you
guys want to get into it all my
interview for tomorrow is with a guy
named max Eluga beer max an old friend
of mine who has a great book coming out
soon called genius foods and he's doing
all this stuff on brain health and food
and diet and exercise and I'm in the
middle of this paleo thing right now so
it was a great time to be interviewed I
also wanted to get away from politics a
little bit this week anyway we just
looked on our back end and it's already
demonetized it's a video about food and
your brain Wow Wow so we're already
fighting the demonization before it even
goes public but it's just like this the
slew of this thing is just it's just
endless super chat congratulations Dave
I really appreciate the work you do
thank you very much
super chat are you gonna go on louder
with Crowder again or would you have
Stephen on your show for a longer format
interview absolutely I'm happy to do it
any time that they ask I do Crowder
probably every maybe other month or so
and we were trying to get him here while
he's on this a little break I know their
work and I think they're redoing his
studio but it didn't quite work out but
he's welcome in this chair any time I
really like Stephen I think he reminds
he gets me to sort it back to my old
comedy self which I wanted to talk to
you guys about in a little bit and I did
have him on once when we were on or a TV
this is god this is over two years ago
now and we did it be a Skype and we
didn't really know each other but you
might you might find that interesting
let's see patreon what guests have you
got lined up or hope to in the new year
so as I said Thomas solo we were just
working out the logistics steven pinker
I think we have in March he'll be in
town for a live event with with Sam
Harris middle of March so I think we
have him for that we've got this YouTube
or this president's week situation lined
up we've got Mike Shellenberger who is
running for president in California and
he originally was running as an
independent although was a lifetime
Democrat now he's running as a Democrat
I just found that out and a really
interesting guy who sort of bounces
between sort of the standard democratic
stuff which is kind of you know and the
progressive stuff that I don't love but
also has this really interesting
libertarian streak that I do like I
think sort of fits within the old
classical liberal line of thinking and a
couple other cool things I don't want to
tip everything off right now you know
this isn't by the way one of the ways
that becoming a patron has its rewards I
do tip off people especially in the
small group chats to some of the things
upcoming oh by the way I see a few
people asking we do sell this classical
liberal t-shirt on our on our merch
store it's teespring
it's teespring calm slash rubin report
or they'll get me the exact link i think
i have the link here do i have the link
here oh how about this people just go to
rubin report comm slash store and it'll
send you over there and we've got all
kinds of stuff we got them we got Rubin
report mugs and sweatshirts and and
stickers and whatever else you got there
okay let's see will you have a youtube
week of all liberal or progressive
leaning guests that's an interesting
idea to really try you know just in the
last couple days I've invited Rob Reiner
on the show I invited this guy Greg
Proops who's a lefty comic who compared
me into to Goebbels the Nazi so I
invited him on the show he blocked me on
Twitter that that's an interesting idea
if I could find five progressives in a
row to do something with that you know
it's interesting the way you wrote it
it's I think it's a liberal or
progressive I would still argue but and
I saw someone break this down on
Facebook once that most of my guests
actually are liberal of course it comes
with that first part and that be in
classical classical liberal these days
as I often say defending my liberal
positions is becoming a conservative
value or defending my liberal values is
becoming a conservative position
depending on which way you want to word
it that liberals right now old-school
liberals certainly are having an easier
time working with or talking to
libertarians conservatives and caps
whatever else it is but it's sort of the
far left these that are that are kind of
lining up against all of us but I'm
always open to having those
conversations truly let's see Dave when
will you cover the gun control debate
and are you willing to sit down with big
names in the Second Amendment
communities such as Tim from Mac so I
don't know Tim specifically we haven't
done the ton on guns but i but i touch
on it with a whole bunch of different
guests i think the most we ever did was
with antonio Okafor who I love Antonia I
think she's really great she's a rising
star by the way in in conservatism or
Republican politics whatever you want to
call it and she really is talking about
why young black women have to arm
themselves to be safe it's an
interesting employee not employees and
it's an interesting play on how this
conversation is framed and she's really
taking the power back to herself and and
I just really I really like her
can you flex those beautiful biceps for
us what's going on there this is this a
flex let how am I doing here that's not
bad that's not bad look at that all
right
that's a you know among all this
grass-fed butter with this paleo thing I
think it's going right to the muscles
okay let's see hey Dave really love your
work been watching for a while now keep
it up question do you like cartoons 90
cartoons like duck tails or bonkers well
I don't know what bonkers is but duck
tails was part of the Disney Afternoon
of course now I was born in 76 so by the
time the Disney Afternoon was really in
its heyday I probably should have been
out there doing some other things but
yeah I watch duck tails and tail spin
and gummi bears what else was on that
that Disney Afternoon I watched all that
stuff but my real my real cartoons of my
childhood
definitely Hema and GI Joe and
transformers were were the big three if
I remember correctly transformers and GI
Joe were on back-to-back on weekdays
maybe around 3:00 and 3:30 when was he
man on was he man on it on at 4:00 I
think it was channel 5 before it was Fox
in New York maybe somebody can correct
me on that oh I just watched a great
documentary actually on on Netflix
they've got this new thing it's called
where the toys are or something like
that where they track like just your
favorite toys from the old days so they
do one on he-man that's the one I saw so
far but I think there's one on GI Joe
probably Star Wars and all that it's
it's pretty cool ok oh and by the way
now I have it in front of me for sure
Peterson and Shapiro Jordan Peterson Ben
Shapiro will be in studio together live
for about a two hour live stream we'll
see how long we can go Peterson's got a
live event in LA that night that I will
be attending by the way Wednesday
January 21st at 12 p.m. that's our live
stream Peterson's event is is that night
oh I'm sorry
January 31st sorry this thing's moving
fast because you guys are asking me a
lot of questions okay patreon have you
ever considered having guests discuss
simple subjects to focus on how
constructive you can make a conversation
over the little things I believe one can
have the right to the right thing to say
but the wrong way to go about it that's
interesting you know I think I think in
general we've done a pretty good job of
that like getting people to just sit
down and explain what they believe but I
think what your question really is is
getting to the heart of what is so wrong
with almost everything right now that
people can agree on basic things we're
always at each other's throats that's a
good idea to kind of pick some really
basic topics maybe that are outside of
the the political realm and and dive
into them that's a good idea let me
think about that I will make note of it
oh by the way so this past weekend you
know I've been telling you guys that
I've wanted to get back into stand-up
for a long time so if you don't know I
did stand-up for about twelve years in
New York City and we took down all my
old videos because I just didn't you
know it was like my formative years a
lot of it was sort of topical stuff I
just didn't want it all on on YouTube
and it's it's not that relevant to the
me of today but anyway because I think
stand-up unfortunately if you look on
Twitter just most of these mainstream
comics it become so hyper partisan and
lefty progressive and it's just
dribbling they're screaming all the time
and telling everyone that they're racist
they're not winning with comedy right
like what would George Carlin be doing
these days you think he'd be bitching
and moaning and demanding books like
Milo's book not be published like I saw
comics doing know that you'd be
attacking relentlessly through comedy
whatever it is that they believe whether
they wanted to attack Trump or the left
or whatever so finally I've mentioned it
a couple times on air David Smalley when
I had him in
I said all right I'm booking something
at the Comedy Store so I made my return
to stand up on Saturday night at the
Comedy Store here in LA sold-out room
and I don't want to pat myself on the
back and and Rucka if you're watching he
was there you guys no youtuber I'm Rucka
he was there he can confirm this and a
couple a couple of you guys that showed
up because I tweeted out I mean I killed
like I just somehow like got back to my
full roots it was all coming back to me
and the you know it's like I know what
I'm saying now in terms of good comic
has to have two things basically you got
to say something now I think most comics
are deficient at this part like really
try to say something that's true most
comics you know they talk about I can't
tie my shoes oh this happened to me in a
lullaby like I'm some sort of pathetic
weirdo okay but I think if you say
something true that's what a truly
transcendent comic does and if I really
go back into this that's what I would
want to do so I know what I'm saying now
and the comic tricks that I learned all
those years I just kind of have to get
them all tuned right get all my my tools
sort of lined up properly but for that
night it came back I mean I crush there
was a point where I said to the audience
I was like I think I'm about done here
and they applauded to keep me on stage I
went we should have got some video of it
I wish we did but in any event I don't
think I'm really going back into
stand-up in the conventional sense like
I want to be at the clubs again it's a
it's a really tough life I live that
life literally twelve years standing out
on street corners handing out tickets
fortunately now because you know of
certain successes that I've reached I
wouldn't have to do that anymore but I'm
thinking maybe I'm gonna do like twenty
shows just random nights that I'm gonna
pick to do shows and then I'm gonna rent
out a theater and do like an hour-long
special and then we'll probably just
post it here or we'll sell it or
something like that it's like we can do
everything without mainstream anymore
which is pretty awesome and it was just
nice to get back to that piece of myself
you know what I mean like it was such an
important piece probably the most
important piece of my personality for
for I mean literally 12 years right out
of college I started in 98 my first
stand-up gig was in May of 98 that's
crazy that's almost 20 years ago god
that's bananas
okay super chat I learned so much from
your show this is the kind of stuff that
the internet makes
well this is true democracy love from
Morocco I would love to visit Morocco my
brother-in-law is Moroccan do you make
shakshuka I believe that is a Moroccan
dish which I actually pretty decent at
making let's see will you be a guest at
Milo's new show at some point does Milo
have a new show I've been I've been
pretty busy I guess Milo has a new show
I assume he would have me on 20 bucks on
super chat hey Dave I'm a gay classical
liberal as well in the UK surrounded by
leftist gay friends I can't say anything
reasonable without being called ignorant
or misinformed it's like beating my head
against a brick wall any ideas you know
I've talked about this a little bit but
I see all of the minority community
splitting and you just got to be awake
enough to see it and and you'll see it I
promise you will I see the black
community splitting watch what Candice
Owens is doing on Twitter right now put
aside our little guys guys guys save
Dave thing okay but look what she's
doing and look at the explosion that
she's creating she's working with
Charlie Kirkland on last week a turning
point USA and she's really catching fire
right now talking about black issues
from a conservative perspective I think
the gay community is starting to realize
you don't have to be a pure leftist and
believe in collectivism and groupthink
you know part of the gay history was
sort of being kind of subversive and you
had your own clubs and your own whatever
now I was never really into that stuff
and I was closeted for a long time and I
was not like a real partier and sort of
like going out and getting wasted and
dancing I'm a horrible dancer I danced
like Bill Cosby which at one time was
funny but now he's the biggest serial
rapist of all time less funny
I heard he just did stand-up last night
again the eighty years old I don't know
what happened with that but in any event
I truly believe that that's so much of
the gay identity is based on being an
individual be be yourself right like if
you're gonna come out and tell the world
Wow my sexuality is different right like
that's something that's so personal and
so individual to you why then push
yourself into some group think
collectivist nonsense so I think a lot
of gays I mean I hear this all the time
because I get a ton of emails like this
and I see what people say to me on
Twitter and Facebook and all that and
even when I go out I used to live in
West Hollywood which is literally the
gayest
on earth they have rainbow crosswalks
and people would come up to me and say
Dave I can't talk about this stuff with
my friends they've gotten so hysterical
so I think there's some cool stuff
happening in the black community I think
it's happening in the gay community I
think it's happening in the Jewish
community I think it's happening in the
Asian community in the Indian community
that people are realizing if you don't
want to be judged as a group doesn't
mean you have to be a card-carrying
Republican tomorrow I'm certainly not
but what it does mean is you have to
reevaluate and stop you know yeah you
probably I'm gonna guess to the person
that wrote this that you're probably a
thoughtful decent human being and if
your friends are gonna you know tell you
that you're racist or you're a bigot or
whatever because you feel differently on
taxes or you feel differently about
immigration or whatever it is you know
at some point it's unfortunate I always
say the thing about don't lose friends
over politics but it's um you get to a
point with that where you can always
turn the other cheek but then at some
point you need friends that enrich you
too and I still have some struggles with
this in my own person life with friends
right now believe it or not
maybe I'll expand on that at some other
point but sacrificing your own thoughts
to hang out with a couple people
probably not the greatest idea okay back
over to patreon will you ever come over
to the UK to do some talks around
universities and then there's another
one come to the UK please yes we are
we're working on a couple things I have
not been to London since I was only
there once I was only in the UK once
since 1997 which is a long time ago I
did a sort of the European thing and I
have not yet 1997 so I'm long overdue so
let's see can you see a competitor
youtuber rising as as the anti right
ideology eventually eats itself look
there's a lot going on in this space
like everybody knows that if you're
following my twitter feed and you see
how quickly we get to monetize the
second we put up a video and then what
what's happening right now is it gets D
monetized for that first 24 hours I have
to publicly fight it then if then they
do they do monetize it usually not all
of them but they usually monetize it the
vast majority of them at this point but
they do it 24 or 48 hours later
virtually all of your views I would
guess at least 75% of your views
come in that 24 to 48 hour period
because that's how the algorithm works
the algorithm is pushing things out that
are new products excuse me so what
they're doing is they're they're like
whacking us with a bat we're now we're
down and we're laying there and we're in
pain and then 24 hours later they're
sending us the ambulance so it's a
shitty situation I'd I have said this a
thousand times and I know that my haters
are gonna miss quote me on it as always
I don't know that they're targeting me
or targeting non leftists or targeting
concern I don't know exactly what's
going on but that's part of the problem
I want the company to be more
transparent I Love You Tube I can say
that with no reservations all of my
success the reason what you guys are
watching right now right I think some
people are watching on Facebook as well
but I mean it's all because of YouTube
these amazing tools that they give us
and by the way no one's forcing me to be
here no one's forcing me to do this so I
want this thing to be better so I'm
trying actually to be completely
consistent with the rest of my views
which are I don't want the government to
have to tell them what to do you know
Prager you and I you know my feelings
about Dennis and I love what Prager you
is doing they're involved in a lawsuit
they're going that route my preference
and I'm not privy to all the details of
the lawsuit I don't know everything
that's happened to them so I can't
comment fully on that but what I could
say is my preference would be the exact
same thing as the gay cake situation
which is I don't want to force them to
do anything but I can use my voice to
help influence them and I think that's
what I've been able to do and as I said
despite all that our interview for
tomorrow with max Luger beer which is
about brain health and food was already
deep monetized so this is what we're up
against so do I think something else is
gonna come yeah there is somebody out
there or you know a a confederacy of a
bunch of millionaires that are looking
at this and going wow there's a real
problem here and this is the beauty of
capitalism this is the beauty of free
market ideas you don't have to have the
government do everything I don't need
the government to create a YouTube
alternative what I need or what I would
prefer is that somebody's gonna come in
and see a gap in the market and get in
and fill that gap and then let some
competition let them fight it out and
then we can all go you know what
actually YouTube was better or you know
what let's all jump to this one or let's
cross post on both or whatever it is
let's see
favorite animated movie Oh without
question
the 19 is it 85 or 84 Transformers movie
it is so much better than that my
numbing drivel that Michael Bay I'm a
free speech guy but Michael Bay should
be in jail for this crap
these movies are horrific I mean I
watched that last one the the one you
know the British one I don't know what
the hell I literally had no frickin clue
what the movie was about I have no idea
but they're all horrible and they all
progressively got worse first one was
alright the second one was an
abomination third one might have been a
teeny bit better fourth one was horrific
and the last one's not even a movie they
need another word for it the 1984
Transformers movie which came between
seasons two and three of the original
transformers cartoon that I referenced
before Orson Welles as the voice of
Unicron the death of Optimus Prime the
death of Starscream and the death of
many other characters which was sort of
a ploy because they wanted to create
some new toys the music is eighties
awesomeness like it's not actually
journey and you guys probably know I
love the band journey but there's so
much of that like 80's awesome music the
animation is awesome Robert Stack is the
voice of not not Optimus Prime he's the
voice of Magnus prime someone help me
here Ultra Magnus just so much good
stuff and it's all the original voices
you know Frank Welker it's Megatron and
and Soundwave the original voice of
Starscream who is that by the way it was
a guy that also did the voice of Cobra
Commander in the GI Joe cartoon he was a
comedian Chris something or other lose
Chris something and I think with an L he
actually died but ever off the new ones
are just terrible but that 84
Transformers movie is spectacular it's
just I cried I saw that in the movie
theater my grandma took my brother and I
I was I was probably if it was 84 I was
about 8 9 and I cried in the movie
theater to that movie Facebook holy cow
never saw you in a t-shirt some guns
there yeah I'm on this workout thing
right now and yeah I've been I've been
working out and just trying to eat right
I haven't been drinking I'm gonna try to
roll this in to at least I'm doing I
have so much travel in September doing a
bunch of gigs and some other stuff that
I don't want to fully get into right now
but because of that I'm just trying to
like get my in order you know you
mean like December rolled around it's
holiday parties and all this and I was
just like eating a lot and drinking a
lot and and also because of my travel in
the last two months it's hard when
you're bouncing around hotels and
airports and everything else that you
know I get a lot of chick-fil-a in
December I know a lot of people owe you
a chick-fil-a you must hate gay people
but I I saw gay people at chick-fil-a
and they enjoy the chicken sandwich
I love the chicken sandwich what can I
tell you let's see tell me about the
artwork behind you so curious so this is
patreon so the artwork behind me so
first you can't see this one so I know
some of you know that there's a there's
one of me as han Solo and Chewbacca
that's by a great artist by Mike
Dennison who's doing some great stuff
with the Golden Girls that probably some
of you have seen this piece here just
this I charge us I think we got this in
Melrose trading post here in LA I'm not
too sure this piece is by a wonderful
artist Kalin Rose Janet her website is
Kalyan Rose Janet calm that's an
original piece that she designed for the
Reuben report but said she does sell
prints of them as well as prints of the
giant piece that we have behind the
guests here and they're both they were
both commissioned by us for the Reuben
report also she painted David give me
the exact numbers on this I believe it
is a 5 foot by 7 foot view of the
Millennium Falcon going into hyperspace
I am right on that 5 foot by 7 foot we
commissioned her to do this and it's in
our lounge here and that's where we do a
lot of our work where we have our
meetings sometimes the guests hang out
in there and prints are available for
all these it's Kalin Rose Janet dot-com
and she's and she's really just just a
brilliant artist it would be awesome if
you Crowder and Owen Benjamin did a
comedy I'd love to do that I just said
200 and yesterday on on Twitter that I'd
love to start doing some comedy stuff
with him because we're obviously drawing
a lot of the same people these days so
he's looking into that super chat and he
plans to run for public office good god
no I think I can do my thing here and
that's better but you know what if
Shapiro runs if Shapiro becomes
president maybe I'll be press secretary
how about that I probably just got
myself into a lot of trouble okay
I am taking questions in case you can't
figure out what I'm doing right
I'm taking questions on on super chat
and on patreon and by the way as always
this show is fully fan funded by you
guys you enable us to do what we want
when we want to allow me to be my own
boss and grow the business properly and
we've got a lot of cool stuff we just
met with our accountants and financial
people we're trying to figure out a lot
of cool things that we can do for the
next year that I'm really psyched about
and let's see
super chat some seem angry you don't
push more but your style seems to be
more about finding where you can relate
to the person and getting their story is
that your intention I like your style
it's Rueben report not Ruben Rumble well
I do want to do something where we bring
in 30 people here I start with one and
then every two minutes we bring in
another one and we just beat the
out of each other we toss each other off
the set that would be a great idea will
baby get to that one day we got to work
with the with the insurance people on
that emma is like up in my lap right now
listen as for my as for my style I like
what I do you guys seem to like what I
do I know that there's a certain you
know I have a very devoted group of of
virtually all anonymous trolls that that
want to just start and if they
don't like what I do alright don't watch
the show if you don't like it don't
watch but if you don't like you can
complain about it too look as I say
often I'm I'm not perfect there are
times actually where I'll be
interviewing someone and they'll say
something but then they kind of keep
going I'm like I got to get back to that
and then conversations just go in
different ways you know Larry King who I
consider the the king of interviewing
who's become a friend of mine and he's
been a mentor to me and one of the most
wonderful people I know on this planet
when he was in the height of his success
on CNN interviewing the Pope and the
president and the Dalai Lama and the
cast of friends and then a porn star and
whatever that was on any given night
people used to have that same criticism
of him so if your criticism of me is
that I'm too much like Larry King I take
that as a great compliment
that being said maybe five years from
now as I've evolved and and and the
world changes and everything else I'll
look back and I'll go oh man I really
should have done that there or this
there nobody's perfect how many of you
are absolutely perfect at your job every
day but I promise you I do try to get
better all the time and I think that I
think the proofs in the pudding so I
appreciate your support
super chat you're the most truthful
interviewer
on YouTube thank you I don't know how
many people are doing interviews on
YouTube but I'm doing the best I can can
you interview Doug Stanhope I've asked
him a couple times on Twitter and I
think he might have said yes once and
then I don't know what happened with it
I will follow up on that let's see did
YouTube ever interact with your
regarding your capitalism sucks
experiment so for those of you that
weren't following along we did that
socialism is in cool video was that last
week I believe it was last week right
that was our DM and they demonetised it
socialism isn't cool and they D
monetized it so I said let's just do a
test a couple people asked me to do it
on Twitter I thought it was a good idea
where we titled something capitalism
isn't cool then I did a 30-second video
where I said no capitalism is cool we're
just doing a test here for 48 hours
socialism isn't cool was demonetized
and then of course they monetize it
after it gets all the views the
capitalism one was never demonetised so
what does it mean I don't know again
this is where you know you got how much
do you want to go down the conspiracy
route I don't know what the hell is
going on over there but that's again
that's why I want some more transparency
out of them than anything else can you
explain what the Paleo diet is so I've
said paleo a couple times I'm doing a
sort of slow carb which is sort of what
Tim Ferriss talks about in his for our
body but basically I'm doing a lot of
meat fish high in fat and veggies so
like this morning I didn't have
breakfast but I had a cup of coffee
because I cannot function without coffee
I had a within it was a tablespoon of
MCT oil which I believe is an extract of
coconut oil and then a tablespoon of
grass-fed butter so you're getting
you're getting a good amount of fat that
your body can run on and then it looks
for more fat and hopefully it goes too
to your wherever you're storing your fat
most of us in our belly right so I've
been doing this for today is exactly 14
days and we we weighed this morning I
lost exactly 5 pounds in 14 days that's
pretty good and I've been trying to do
some some cardio and I've lifted a
couple times but I got to tell you I
actually feel great the first couple
days were tough like it's just your body
adjusting to no sugar you know pretty
much no booze you can have one
cheat day a week I've only taken one
actually and so you can have some mood
swings at first but I'm actually feeling
pretty good right now
David's actually doing the same diet
right now he's feeling good Amir is
doing like sort of version of it and I
think alexis is also doing a little a
little version of it so we're sort of
doing this as a team and it seems to be
working I mean I've lost weight and I
feel good so yeah we shall see
let's see Facebook Tim Allen or Jay Leno
without question Tim Allen I always like
Tim Allen I always like to stand up from
back in the day home-improvement is an
extremely underrated sitcom and the
coolest thing that I can tell you about
Tim Allen is that he as far as I know
the only person to have a New York Times
best seller New York the number one
movie in America and the number-one
sitcom in America at the same time so he
had Santa Claus home improvement number
one movie number one sitcom and he had
his I believe it's his first book don't
stand close to a naked man or don't
stand too close to a naked man all
number one at the same time I mean talk
about influence and power and like
grabbing your moment also I
think he's really fascinating cuz he's a
rare conservative in Hollywood and he
show Last Man Standing which was just
cancelled and a lot of people think it
was canceled because he's a conservative
because the ratings were actually pretty
solid if you watched it look those style
you know the old-school sitcoms look
down and all of them are sort of just
not great anymore they feel very dated
but what was interesting to me about the
show was that all the jokes were the
reverse the jokes were about Obama they
weren't about the Republicans the jokes
were about his I believe it was his son
or his son-in-law who was like you know
a lefty and to do it into
environmentalism and all that the jokes
were on him so Tim was really doing
something interesting I actually did
bump into him in LA a couple months ago
at an ice cream shop and I talked to him
about coming on my show and we're trying
to work it out with our agents I do hope
it happens and Leno I'm just personally
on a personal note I was just never a
fan of Leno I love Johnny Carson that
was sort of the beginning of my
formative comedy years around eleven
twelve I was born in 76 he retired in 92
I remember staying up that last night
of the last night of the Johnny Carson
Tonight Show I thought he was just cool
and calm and decent I don't know maybe
some of that has seeped into me as an
interviewer so I was more of a letterman
guy if you're looking at it between the
rivalry with those guys
Leno I just thought it was kind you know
what everyone else thought he was just
kind of hacky and you never really knew
what he thought about anything in an odd
way I've come to like him more now
because as we watch all the late and I
comics like you know Kimmel especially
crying every night and Conan's become
very it's a very obvious leftist stuff
and who else Seth Meyers definitely and
Colbert it's like they're all doing the
exact same thing if you took all the
late-night guys the one that's the most
Center or the most right is Bill Maher
which is bananas I mean that's
completely bananas I dropped two f-bombs
there for some reason
where's Prager at and their lawsuit
against YouTube I don't know where
they're at in that lawsuit but by the
way did you see this yesterday so there
was this hack from the I guess these
Turkish hackers on Twitter yesterday and
they took out Sheriff Clark and a couple
other people and they got the Prager you
account for 12 hours the Prager you
account was hacked into last I saw
though I've been taping today they lost
their verification because when you get
verification it's linked to a an email
specific email address but it can't be a
like a Gmail or Yahoo so they changed
their email address they lost
verification they posted you know their
their usual spam nonsense when hackers
do this and I was communicating with the
Prater people they could not get anyone
for a good 12 hours and even when the
count got restored later in the evening
they couldn't get anyone from Twitter to
respond to them on Twitter itself or on
the phone or email or anywhere else
which is and I publicly went after
Twitter for it but it's interesting
because if you look at the Twitter
support at Twitter support all day long
all they do is respond to people people
say I don't like Twitter how can we help
you
I can't tweet how can we help you
meanwhile I tweeted about this to defend
Prager they got that I think it's some
one of them at least got a thousand
retweets that's like they don't even
bother responding so what does that all
mean how many times can these platforms
kick us in the head before we go maybe
they're intentionally doing this but I
just don't know by the way I asked
Jack from Twitter to come on the show he
had told me once privately that he would
do it I haven't heard back since but I
would love to have him here and again I
love these platforms I want them to work
the best way that they can all right
jumping back to super chat which
conservative would you like to have on
your show but haven't had the chance yet
um I mean the most obvious answer to
this if we're just in the general sense
of what a conservative is I mean
obviously having Trump or Trump jr. or
someone from the administration I think
would be would be fantastic it's one
thing to rail on the mainstream media
all the time you guys know I'm all about
it and they deserve to crumble but
you're gonna have to start at you have
to go then to alternative media go to
new media start answering some questions
so I would love to in that regard I mean
the really though in the conservative
sense I mean Thomas Saul is answer on
that one and we're gonna make it happen
okay
do you vape well I don't vibe tobacco
but when I do smoke weed and I have a
license don't worry about it you know I
got that bum shoulder and that glaucoma
I have a I guess that's a bait that I
have is that of eight that thing's a
vape yeah and I like I like a hybrid
like a little more indica heavy I just
want to melt into the couch and watch
The Simpsons basically I don't need to
smoke to like be outside or function or
any of that kind of stuff
hey Dave I'm a student and video game
design just wanted to say your videos
have helped me debate many sjw's within
my interest industry thanks for all your
hard work question are you inviting
Colin Moriarty back yes Colin we'll be
back in studio in March I don't know
that we settled on the date but we're
definitely doing that you know I've been
trying to get back into video games and
Colin got me a Playstation 4 and you
know mostly though cuz I don't have a
lot of time I can't do these giant
massive multiplayer role-playing things
I just don't have time and I don't even
have like the mental like ability to do
it at this point because you got to
devote so much of yourself to that so I
like a lot of 2d shooters
I was playing what the hell is it called
bangbros where's that a porn site I was
playing bro-bro town oh man what the
hell's that game called David help me
out here bro broforce
we're not bang bros that's something
else don't go to bang bros calm people
fors which is fun multi it's sort of
like contra on sterile
and you can play it's for player you
know all local which is cool let's see
will you please interview dick Masterson
of the dick show a couple of people have
mentioned that I don't know who he is
but I'll look into it Camille Polly oh
yeah we've reached out to her a couple
times I know she's friends with
Christina Hoff Sommers I'll follow up on
that and Tommy Lehren you know I've
gotten to know Tommy she's actually a
lovely girl I know she gets a lot of
and she says some controversial
things but I like her I'd be happy to
have her in here I think at the moment
we're waiting to see if Fox will
actually let her do it
Marvel or DC characters comics not
movies I mean without question Marvel I
was always a Marvel guy spider-man was
always my favorite growing up I saw it
because I saw him it's like he was like
a kid like I was a kid with you know
with great power comes great
responsibility Uncle Ben that's as good
as it gets in terms of quotes you know
Stan Lee who's now what 96 years old
I mean think of the mind of Stanley
Stanley came up with spider-man he came
with x-men all of those x-men which most
of them could have stood on their own as
comic book characters you know between
between Wolverine and Professor X and
Magneto and ever and Miss a mystique and
the whole thing but he came ago that he
came up with the Fantastic Four although
nobody really cares about that Fantastic
Four he came up with Silver Surfer he
came up with all of this stuff I mean
the guy's just I came up with Deadpool I
think I mean everything Deadpool by the
way I can't wait for part two part one
was awesome
let's see jump back to super chat I dare
you to have David call Stein on the show
I'll give you 500 dollars if you do
cheers mate I have no idea who that is
but I'll look into it
super chat you are right I can't be
intellectually dishonest with myself by
stifling my opinion for people who would
call me a name rather than have a
dialectic how responsive you are you to
email I'd like to discuss this in more
detail I'm glad you asked that my email
is in saying I try I at least read
basically everything I at least read it
although a lot of times people send me
like essays and pages long thing telling
me their life story if you get me within
a couple sentences that's really that's
the best way if you're trying to email
me it's Rubin report calm slash contact
I should probably should have even said
that even though it's public but but try
to keep it somewhat brief that's the
best chance but if I didn't respond to
you it's not because I didn't like you
or I did
you know you didn't say anything
worthwhile it's just I'm trying to
manage time and all kinds of other stuff
reminder guys why are we doing this
we're doing this because we cracked
600,000 subscribers overnight we are fan
funded on patreon patreon comm slash
Ruben Report and you guys always get
advance notice on these live streams and
all sorts of other stuff if you are a
patron we have one-on-one hangouts which
I think we might be sold out of them not
sure but we have small group chats video
chat where I chat with people from all
over the world in small groups it's cool
I spend one day a month from 8 a.m. to
about 9 p.m.
literally talking to people all over the
world my audience that funds this show
it's pretty awesome so I'll talk to
someone in Japan next thing you know I'm
in Mexico next thing you know I'm in
Australia next thing you know I'm in the
UK then I'm in Kansas and it's really
cool just getting to know all these
different people and by the way the
audience has wildly different political
views forget about the different is
plenty of the diversity of all color and
sexuality and a lot of stuff but they
have wildly different views and I love
hearing like just what everyone's going
through I talked to two Tabora in
Hungary and I talked to Jessica in
Australia and all sorts of other people
and it's it's awesome I talked to Steve
in Canada everybody Oh a couple people
asking about a link to the artist
website it's Kalyn Rose Janet calm CA
yli n Rose Janet calm
okay back to patreon please come to
Germany despite bear deep and
experiences with dirt Smeagol yeah they
wrote a really shitty article about me
after spending literally a day with me
what I did two interviews with Yasmin
Muhammad and Faisal Saitama thar then I
did a free speech event with Colin at
USC and they wrote just a horrific lying
absolutely lying defamatory article
about me how I'm I'm in the all right
and all this nonsense of course when I
asked the writer after if he wanted to
discuss any of my family that died in
the Holocaust he didn't seem to want to
do that by the way he also interviewed
me for about two hours in our control
room did not quote me once in the
article because there is a law in
Germany that if they're gonna write
about you and they quote you they have
to run the quotes by you so this guy
spends all day with me
writes this horrible article and then
and then doesn't even quote me once he
claimed that basically that the event
that Colin I and Steve Simpson did from
the I Rand Institute we did a free
speech of that very much in line with
everything else we do
he claimed that basically it was a hate
rally and the article ends with
something about how the the security
guards were clutching their guns at the
end as the door is closed you can watch
the video online I believe it's on the
iron rands channel it's about an hour
and a half of us we had a great time
there's tons of laughs
there was no hate there there was no
racism there or anything so yeah the
media just sucks but what I love to come
to Germany yes it's I've never been you
know a couple countries that I really
want to get to and I and hopefully in
the next year or two we can make it
happen
Japan and Australia at the top - as I've
said before but I'd love to get to
Germany I really want to get back to the
UK and makan I've only spent one guy I
spent like two hours in France once
about like a $87 baguette so I would
like to get back there Dave is the
candidacy of Chelsea Manning serious in
the States can a convicted traitor hold
office so I don't know about the
legality of the second part I'm on the
first part I don't know if it's serious
or not her Twitter feed is just
completely bananas I think she's just
trolling everybody her one campaign
video was the worst kind of scary
politics of how evil everything is I
don't know what she stands for really
other than she doesn't really like our
security services but I but I would love
to interview her I'd love to find out
what the truth is on any of that stuff
so yes I would be happy to have you
considered taking the show on the road
yes we have so I've been doing a lot of
college gigs I'll be in Ithaca next
month I'll be a University of Tampa I'm
doing something in DC with students for
liberty and DC home I'll be a Berkeley
actually in a month or two a whole bunch
of other stuff
and I have a meeting with my agents this
week about maybe taking the show on the
road more I'd love to do something at
universities where we grab one professor
from the University and then one out of
my crew out of this intellectual dark
web as Eric Weinstein has called it
where we just grabbed like one of the
cool people that I mean you know in this
within this machine whatever you want to
call this thing whether it's Peterson
your superiors or Sam or Eric or Brad or
whoever it is and
a professor from a university and then
stream them live but actually some of
those events that I just mentioned I
think the Berkeley event definitely the
tap event and some others we are going
to be streaming live on our channel so
keep an eye out for that I'll jump back
over to super chat
do you anticipate doing any further work
with the ion Rand Institute thanks for
your incredible classy work much love
from a flyover country I love you fine
people you know I grew up in New York
and I live in LA so I never lived in a
flyover state but I find everyone in the
middle of the country to be quite
pleasant yes a couple of those events
that I just mentioned I believe that
Tampa I'll be with your own Brooke at
the University of Tampa
I think that's March 27th and Berkeley I
believe that's also a are I I don't know
the date off the top of my head let's
see oh this is good this is good
first $66 on super chat which I believe
is a reference to order 66 Dave what
color would your lightsaber be I think I
identify the most with obi-wan you know
like I knew the like obi-wan knew when
things were good and then he had to
fight the bad in the later years that's
kind of how I feel like I knew when the
left was good I knew when liberalism was
good and maybe I'm training a group of
Jedi that are younger than me it
probably doesn't bode well for my future
I probably get sliced in half or at
least I disappear into my own robe but
so green Obi Wan's was green I think
mine would be green by the way you guys
already know my thoughts on last Jedi
right so many so many problems so many
problems okay
reminder I see a lot of people asking
about the classical liberal shirt Rubin
report com slash store and you're
helping support the show and getting
these ideas out here thoughts on NBA
officiating is it as bad as the players
are making a team or are we just too old
I love that question because you know
I've been watching the NBA it's one of
the few things that I can I'm able to do
where I can shut my brain off because
even when I'm trying to take a few
minutes for video games it's not really
brain off you know so basketball or if I
watch basically a re-run of Seinfeld or
The Simpsons that I've seen before which
FXX you know that has the whole Simpsons
Catalog these last couple days
they've been in like that those amazing
years of The Simpsons that season 6 to 8
it's comedy perfection every single
episode as for MBA officiating I don't
think it's as bad as the players are
making it seem i think players whine
more than ever before but players have
always whined a lot but there's been bad
officiating over the years and I don't
think there's anything really that is
particularly worse right now then than
it was before do you know of any groups
in Atlanta I can hook up with I really
want to get involved with the
libertarian classical liberal movement
you know off the top of my head I don't
know any groups in Atlanta I did an AR
eye event their student conference was
that the when was that I think that was
in October it was at the W Hotel for a
weekend in Atlanta it was so cool I met
all of these students all about freedom
and liberty and we had we had a great
time but that's not based out of there
specifically but there's definitely some
libertarians there and you could
definitely find them let's see back to
patreon I would love I would like a
Generation X 25 years later interview it
appears our generation grew up and is
also causing a lot of this mess that's
interesting it's interesting because so
I'm Gen X I was born in 76 so that's I'm
like firmly in that Gen X thing so Gen X
basically is the children of the baby
boomers right so we had the what they
call the greatest generation that was
sort of the world war ii generation they
then had a ton of babies that was the
baby boomers then we got Gen X that's
around my age then after that was sort
of Gen Y so that's really I guess if
you're sort of what you're probably
around 35 Gen Y maybe a little younger
and then and then into Millennials and
whatever they're calling this new thing
now the new one whatever they're calling
that new one is sort of interesting
because they're finding that they are
more conservative now they're not
politically correct and hysterical
they're the fund-me makers these young
kids now which is actually super cool as
for Gen X I think a lot of us in Gen X
because of the success of the baby
boomers and the explosion of the middle
class we grew up in a certain amount of
comfort so we we never did anything real
right and I don't I think I've tried to
fight that I think I've tried with what
I do
but could gen-x be better and fired more
yeah but I do see a lot of people my
generation that are waking up to ideas
and by the way for all the craziness
that's happening right now the rich
conversations I'm having all the time
everywhere I go that someone comes up to
me people are engaged in ideas so don't
listen to these people that want to tell
you our horrible everything is because
it really just is not reaction to TYT
hiring dan Rather chuckle air guffaw
from a comedians perspective what do you
think are the best active stand-up
comics out there right now so as I've
said many times George Carlin to me was
the standard-bearer of true
stand-up the guys that also influenced
me I mean Bill Cosby was a huge
influence in mine when I was six years
old and I saw Bill Cosby himself
I was crumbling on the floor I remember
being on the floor as a six-year-old I
think was 1983 seven-year-old buckled
over and laughter watching that special
Bill Cosby himself where he's sitting
there in the brown suit it's comedy
perfection this is putting aside all of
the personal flaws so for me personally
just old ones I would say Carlin Cosby
in a little more of a contemporary sense
Jerry Seinfeld Dave Chappelle Chris Rock
those were sort of the main ones but in
the contemporary sense you know I'm a
little out of the loop of like who's
like in it right now it was cool being
back at a comedy club being back at the
Comedy Store and and seeing what's going
on with comedy but I'm are query's I'm
going to make a major dent in the comedy
situation in this country this year they
I don't even want to do it I mean that's
the thing I'm free because I don't want
to do it but they've dragged me back in
the more I try to get out the more they
suck me back in any plans to go on
compound media like Michael malice or a
and a right up your alley aaaa
who is that I really like Michael malice
what a what a wild interview we had I
don't know that I've ever had anyone in
here that surprised me more or
challenged conventional thinking more
than Michael malleus he's a really
interesting guy he's a little kind of
little Willy Wonka Sh
but I really liked him compound media
that's run by COO Mia I think Oh a na
who don't I'm not sure who that is but I
think that's where Gavin McGinnis now is
- I
be happy to go on and guest on some of
the shows but I'm I mean I'm very happy
with independence as I've told you guys
before we've got a couple interesting
offers my agents bring things across to
me and it's like for me to give this up
yes I can make a lot more money going
with the network or something but to
give this up this ability to do what I
want when I want do a live stream like
this because we were just ready to roll
do two shows this morning we got we'll
do two more tomorrow then I'm not taping
on on Friday but we have other stuff to
do but control my destiny and and be so
directly connected with you it would
take a lot I'm not saying it can never
happen right I'm just not I would never
say that but it would take a lot it
really would all right jumping back to
the super chat the regressive left
placed the group before the individual
sort of white soup right supremacists on
the all / far right they place the group
before the individual in terms of skin
color why is one left and one right well
that's that's an interesting thought and
it's a great point you know people
always say the Nazis were far-right the
Nazis were the National Socialists
actually which is really left putting
that aside because it's because people
just go crazy when you say anything like
that and they really wanted state power
right the Nazis wanted to state power
but you're completely right if your if
your movement is a white identitarian
movement meaning you think that this
country belongs to white people based on
the colors of their skin not only is
that antithetical to all of the laws of
America and the Declaration of
Independence and the Constitution and
our Bill of Rights
it is a collectivist movement so admit I
don't know that they don't admit that
they're collectivist but you don't own
this country by any religion color
ethnicity or anything else this country
there's a reason this place is the most
amazing place ever we are a melting pot
that is done multiculturalism better
than everybody else literally everybody
else no country has taken more people
from more places on earth and given them
more opportunity have we screwed up do
we have problems yes duh but that being
said we've built something amazing here
and all of these collectivist movements
wherever they are they're the bad guys
most of them happen to be on the Left
right now but if we're considering the
all I don't want to say
right because mostly that's me makers
and silly people doing nonsense but if
you want to take the the whatever the
racist elements are of this white
supremacist whatever the hell that thing
is it's based in collectivism so yes it
is bad
let's see hey Dave would you consider
having James T Harris on the show I have
a feeling you guys would have a lot of
great things to talk about don't know
who he is off the top of my head David
if you could just jot that one down
we'll look into it
my man dog Jones on super Chet do you
own any other shirts I've only what I've
literally worn this shirt twice once was
the first come back after I took my
month off in August for our first live
stream and now I'm wearing it one other
time my friend let's see oh how about
this one so I just mentioned our Michael
malleus interview which I said is just
one of the most interesting interviews
I've ever done he's there's something
sort of really fascinating by this Emira
is telling me right now we went into the
back catalogue be monetized we talked
about North Korea and we talked about
freedom
deema okay YouTube not friendly for
advertisers whatever the hell that means
okay let's see do you think a new video
platform based around free speech is
possible I've considered building one
but Google's pockets are deep and reach
extensive look as I said before I think
it is possible it's going to take major
major money but as far as you doing it
yourself and one guy versed Google well
there was a biblical story I don't quote
the Bible that often of David versus
Goliath so if we have to do Dave versus
goggle here you know I guess maybe we'll
have to do it but everything being equal
I'd rather Google get their
together so we shall see
Jeru but who's the most handsome ben
shapiro and drew Clavin or steven
crowder Clavin is a fine-looking older
man I mean to rock that sort of the
chrome dome you know as they say the
fully shaven head I don't know what
level of hair loss he was actually at
before he fully shaved but he said he's
a mature older man there you go we'll
Clay Travis or Jason Whitlock returned
to park to talk more about sports how
about a Sports special that is a great
idea for sure let's make sure to note
that guys I'd love to have them both in
together and I know we were working on a
dinner next time Clay's in town but yeah
we'll get them both in here and you know
we'll do a whole show on sport we're
of course is infected by politics these
days but we'll try to focus on that
do you believe any harder drugs such as
shrooms or LSD should be legalized well
I'd be a hypocrite if I didn't say the
truth should be legalized in my college
days I did shrooms a bunch probably ten
or twelve times over the course of a
couple years I've done them a few times
since college one actually wasn't that
long ago I just did like a tiny bit and
I had I would describe what a lot of
people would call low dosing and I
really just had a nice time with a
couple friends and like that was it and
yeah I felt fine after I didn't hurt
anybody or do any self harm or harm to
anyone else or anything like that so
again and that's also a completely
natural substance it grows on horseshit
which is kind of nasty but and it tastes
that way by the way but I don't see any
real reason that you and by the way
they've found that there's some
medicinal value in it and that it can
help people deal with depression and all
that I don't have any real problem with
that I think the other one you said was
LSD I can only tell you antic totally I
did do LSD once a long time ago when I
was in college I had a terrible
experience on it that being said I know
that there are many studies again that
helped people deal with PTSD and chronic
depression and all sorts of things so I
would need to see a little more research
on that specifically as a general rule
though you know you know my feelings on
the drug wars is ridiculous obviously
marijuana should be legal nobody's
smoking marijuana and going out there
and robbing banks and it's far less
deadly than even alcohol so I still
haven't seen a good argument against
that what I have what has been nice as
I've seen most of the conservatives
these days they take the libertarian
approach to it which is which is I think
fair okay let's jump over to Facebook
I've been ignoring you find people on
Facebook would you interview with Ronan
Fowler Rose McGowan the man who broke
the Weinstein Weinstein I should say
sorry Bret and Eric scandal
you've never discussed the Hollywood sex
crime scandal until on the godfathers
podcast so I was on GAD SADS channel by
the way and if you and I actually did
open up all he asked me some really good
questions it was just last week and I
opened up a lot about some personal
stuff and we talked for probably an hour
and a half so if you're not tired of
hearing me talk you could jump over
there when we're done with this but we
did get into that a little bit yeah I
haven't done much on it I do have
someone potentially lined up that's
actually really big in that
basse I don't want to say much beyond
that one more from here's patreon what's
the key to getting someone to having an
open mind in conversation about politics
it's a really tough question right
because especially I think at least
these days when you're dealing with
someone in this tent this tends to be
people on the left right now
progressives because they've accused
everyone of being a racist and a bigot
and they and they this is why Peter
Bogosian who's become a good friend of
mine who watch our last interview where
he really lays out what postmodern
leftism is he calls it a secular
religion but in most religions there's a
Redemption narrative where you can come
back and be better with them you can't
because if you're born a straight white
male or a cisgender mama you're guilty
you're guilty and you must bow at the
altar of diversity all the time what a
horrible way to view the world horrible
way you are not guilty because of your
skin color you are not your you're
guilty if you do bad things or whatever
else but not because of your immutable
characteristics I think that Martin
Luther King guy might've said something
about that what's the best way to talk
to these people I find that the best way
I I had an instance I think I mentioned
this once I had an instance just a few
months ago where a very very good friend
of mine virtually since I was born
that's someone I've known truly my
entire life we got into it about
politics at a bar and and he's a far
lefty he knows my positions obviously
and we got into it and at one point I
said to him because he was really all
over me and I wasn't even in the mood to
talk politics actually and I was trying
to talk about sports or something else
and I said do you think it's possible
that I believe what I believe as much as
you believe what you believe and without
hesitation he said no and I was like man
that is a really shitty way to view the
world that is a really shitty way to
presume the worst intentions of your
ideological opponents but more
importantly your friends so that's one
thing to never do is that my friend in
this case I believe he's wrong about all
this he's a far left he buys into all
this progressive and all the
suppression olympics nonsense but i
believe he believes it
and if you want to have a conversation
at an honest level where we can really
get into why that's why I think it's bad
while you think it's good then I'll do
it but if you start a conversation by
saying I am so right that you can't even
believe what you say to believe that's a
really horrible place to jump off of and
I know it's kind of funny for you guys
to hear me say that like I'm still going
through that but I know you guys are
going through it all the time your
favorite music I never hear you mention
music so usually in my house so for like
because we work from home and you know
so our office is an effector in my house
we usually have like some chill ambient
stuff playing so I repeat you guys know
this I really like music without words
so I like a lot of the chill ambient
like hotel bar lounge stuff that you can
I have Spotify we have a lot of cool
ones you know one day I'll post a
playlist of stuff that I have on there I
think maybe we can share the Spotify
playlist my favorite bands in general
though journeys my favorite band of all
time Fleetwood Mac number two I got
engaged at a Fleetwood Mac concert here
in LA I love Billy Joel I love I love
80s classic rock as a general theme like
they were always saying something in the
music oh you know a great guy if you
like sort of the ambient but like kind
of uplifting fun stuff there's a guy by
the name of Pat Metheny just kind of fun
like your brain will kind of feel good
after there's also a channel on Spotify
called chill brain it's a little more a
little more up afternoon kind of stuff
and I also have a sex playlist but I'm
not going to tell you about that right
now okay
super chat $5 take yourself for a drink
Dave great job I will thank you very
much what's a good way to learn to do
comedy and stand-up if you're starting
from scratch no matter what anyone tells
you there is only one thing you can do
which is get out there and do it go to
those shitty open mics they suck the
comics are there probably stealing your
material nobody's even list there are
they're stealing your material are not
listening go out there bark if you have
to that's what we call barking when we'd
stand outside on even know that people
really do it anymore but stand outside
hand out tickets I used to do I mean for
years I did it and either or either
sleet nor rain nor snow I didn't stop me
I'd always did it you know there a
bringer shows where you can bring a
couple friends and get stage time but
that's kind of
tough on your friends and it's not the
best way to get better just do it do it
do it if it's in you you won't be able
to stop and actually even though I did
it for 12 years in New York the reason I
stopped was because I started getting
success else wah elsewhere because I
realized that my guys that were out of
my crew the best comics I knew with
really only one exception the best
comics I knew all disappeared or failed
or couldn't take it anymore and some of
the worst ones succeeded one or two
exceptions to that and I realized I was
like wow if I get on Twitter if I
started doing stuff on YouTube that's
how I can affect people so just get out
there and do it it's literally the only
advice that there is let's see hey Dave
did you watch Sargon's debate against
Richard Spencer and how would you feel
about hosting a rematch I didn't see it
let me let me take a look when I have a
chance and then I can address that
directly jump over to patreon hey Dave
could you get Tim from the military arms
channel to discuss guns Second Amendment
rights the NRA etc etc I don't know who
he is David could we add that to the
list please let's see Facebook if you
could interview anyone living or dead
who would it be
I'd say living probably that was a joke
people living or dead who would it be
living or dead I mean if there was one
person I could truly sit in that chair
across from it would be George Carlin he
was to me the greatest comedy mind we've
ever had and he had such an innate
understanding of what's happening even
right now he would be railing against
all of this politically correct drivel
but he would be doing it with comedy and
I would just love to get inside his
brain you know I become one of my best
friends on this planet is Kelly Carlin
his daughter who I've had on the show
and we're gonna we're gonna do something
with her in in March actually she's now
teaching courses helping people
disconnect and you guys know how
important getting off the doing the
digital detox thing is to me but I've
learned a lot of insight about George
one of the best nights that I've won I
think one of the best things I've had to
happen to me in my life actually very
early on when I met Kelly she had all of
George's old you know records and
writings and scribbles and notes and
notepads and all the stuff in a room
that you said was sort of his
room in her house and she has since
donated all of this to the I think it's
the American comedy Institute or the
Museum of comedy which is in upstate New
York but she had all this stuff and she
let me and another comic go into the
room and kind of read jokes back and
forth it was so cool so if he was at a
restaurant let's say and he got the bill
he would write he would take the bill he
would write the premise on the front or
the set up on the front and the
punchline on the back and we were kind
of stoned and we just went back and
forth reading stuff to each other and I
was I was crying
I mean tears of happiness and and
laughter but crying yeah what are your
thoughts on fake news hysteria yeah you
got a tune out a little bit out of the
mainstream noise it's just noise every
day another another russia' thing that
then this had you know they went from
all the rushes stuff and now we've got
him on this and then that doesn't work
and it gets aimed back at the Clintons
or the Democrats and then that happens
and then they go okay we're done with
Russia so now it's about Trump's mental
health and then when it turn out his
mental health was fine now it's about
Trump's weight and the media is just
beating everyone garbage all the time
it's important to be aware and and you
know what listen watch Phil DeFranco if
you have a chance watch some Joe Rogan
listen to some Sam Harris watch Jordan
Peterson I mean so many the people that
are in the mix here you will get a
better more holistic sense of what's
actually happening in the world
then then watching mainstream media I
mean I watch CNN
I don't watch CNN I watch it meaning
I'll turn it on for a split second just
to see what's on the crawl and every
other time it's Trump drinks too many
diet cokes Trump said this about and
it's not this isn't real let's deal in
reality people all right are we seeing a
return this is Facebook we're seeing a
return to the Enlightenment liberalism
versus authoritarian dichotomy turning
away from right left debate love the
show keep it up so my direct message
next week which will be a preamble to
having Shapiro and Peterson live I'm
going to address just that so please
stay tuned on that patreon why are you
asking Candis Owens back on to debate I
don't think anyone's to see another save
Dave so look the Candis thing with with
Blair yes was it a show was it
probably
my worst moment in terms of being in
control of what I'm doing here yes many
of you said to me Dave everyone gets one
that's what a lot of patreon people said
Dave that thing was terrible but
everyone gets one look save Dave trended
on Twitter that's pretty cool the memes
that came out of that my favorite one
was the Curb Your Enthusiasm one is the
two of them are shouting across from me
someone lays in the Curb Your Enthusiasm
music as I'm kind of just you know
exasperated what I've done it slightly
differently yes could they have both
done different things yes I think that
what I would say is this I think
everyone deserves a second chance and
I'm certainly not someone that's not
going to give someone a second chance if
their intentions are good
I think Candice is actually doing a lot
of good stuff right now and I think she
deserves a second chance in that regard
and I have no problem giving it to her
all right jump back over to super chat
um Dave I've been watching your shows
for a while and you were one of my
favorite channels thank you have you
tried out to reach have you tried to
reach out to a Esley a renowned thinker
of the Chinese all right I haven't I I
see you gave me his Twitter handle there
I don't want to say it out loud until I
see it see what the feeds like but let
me take a look at that David could we
add that to the list please what's more
important to culture art or politics
this is super chat too so this is this
is a great question
art or politics well if we're if we're
saying that you know everything is art
meaning television movies painting
sculpting stand-up comedy acting or
politics well then I would say it's it's
the former its art in the in the broad
sense of what you mean by art politics I
mean the reason that I'm for classical
liberalism and small government is that
politics shouldn't be that important to
you the the reason everyone's going
crazy these days is because politics has
become a sport politics has infected
everything everywhere you go everyone
wants to talk about politics all the
time that's not good you know one of the
reasons people say to me Dave why don't
you do a daily show we could do a daily
show now I don't even know that it would
be financially sensible because the more
shows we do the more caught it costs us
to do them and the resources and because
the YouTube monetization so bad I don't
even know that we we might end up losing
money but putting
aside I don't think people need to be
thinking about politics all the time I
think if I give you guys one or two
shows a week for an hour or an hour and
a half or sometimes two hours or three
hours and we're gonna do probably two
and a half or three hours with Jordan
and Ben if I give you that and you give
me an exchange two hours of your time a
week with the amount of stuff that's out
there and you take away a little
something III if anything I think would
be insulting to keep jamming that stuff
down your face so I think we have to I
don't think I think actually in the
right sense politics shouldn't be that
important the government should be small
enough they can't that it can basically
keep you safe keep the roads going right
keep schools going I do believe there's
some role for government absolutely but
the government should be small enough
that we don't have to care about it that
much and right now we we care about it
too much because it's the conversation
has just gotten out of control okay oh
you know what I so we can go till about
5:15 so we'll do about a half hour more
at 5:30 I have a one-on-one hangout
because you know when we do these Reuben
report calm / donate if you donate a
certain amount we can do we do monthly
Hangouts but I also do one time if you
just do a one time donation on on PayPal
so I have one at 5:30 so I can't go much
longer than that
super chat hey Dave congrats on the 600
K would you consider interviewing geremy
Handley of the YouTube channel the court
the quartering he recently exposed a
cover-up of sex offenders and Magic the
Gathering Committee I heard a tiny
little something and Rumble about this
on Twitter I don't know that much about
it you know it's funny I get people
asking me all the time they'll send me a
random youtuber key help him do this or
people will say I'm at school and this
is happening it's like I got to kind of
manage the amount of people that I can
sort of help but I'll at least look into
it when I have a moment okay let's jump
back to patreon hey Dave at this point
whenever I'm having a conversation that
gets slightly political with people from
the left I'm afraid that if I say
anything in disagreement they will
accuse me of being a bad person it
becomes a toxic climate where you can't
agree you can't disagree with anything
without being personally attacked any
advice on that I mean again the best you
can do is make it clear that your views
don't come from a racist
views don't come from a bigoted place
where do your views come where do all
the things that I talk about all the
time even these conservatives who I
disagree with on certain things like ben
shapiro on abortion or death penalty or
whatever it is we're both taking
principled stands on where our views
come from right what are the rights that
are given to you in this constitution
and what is the role of government so I
think when you and look the best thing
you can do is try to explain to someone
you do you mean let them tell you to
your face that they think you're a bad
person try it that way do you you know
like tell them okay you know I'm for low
taxes I'm for Less regulation and
they'll go well what about this do you
think I'm a bad person do you think it's
possible we just have a political
disagreement you're supposed to have
political disagreements in societies
like ours you know where they don't have
that many political disagreements North
Korea try that you can have more healthy
political disagreement than America than
any country on earth no one's coming for
you over your political disagreements
you threatened to kill somebody or if
you actually kill somebody that's a
problem you can't come on to my property
and start talking but beyond that
we're supposed to have disagreements be
the best person you can be I try I'm
trying to do it all the time I mean
listen to Jordan Peters and 12 rules for
life
would love to hear a discussion by a
competent subject matter experts making
a clear delineation between classical
liberalism and libertarianism I mean
there's many episodes that I can point
you to I've done a couple DMS on it go
back check my interview from about a
year and a half ago with Steve Davies
from the London it's not from the London
School of Economics the plank I know
where he's from the London Institute of
something somebody help me out here
I'll get it but go back listen to my
interview with Steve Davies go back
listen to my in suit with Randy Barnett
from Georgetown University who is argued
in front of the Supreme Court great
delineations basically the only real
functional difference is that classical
liberals generally tend to see some
usefulness for government where
libertarians it's hard to pin them down
because a libertarian you could be you
could be a total ancap and say that even
the courts and the roads should be
privatized I'm certainly not that but
it's an interesting conversation to have
that's what I had with with Michael
malice and I've had it with several
other people on the show so I would say
a classical liberal is a
more of what I would say is a bit more
of a realistic libertarian but the
arguments of libertarianism any argument
that tells me that the private sector
and free markets and individualism can
beat out what the government can do I
love those arguments and I can at least
intellectually go there but at the same
time I went to a state school State
University of New York at Binghamton I
got a good education I went to a good
public school it's a Blue Ribbon public
school and I got a good high school
education so I believe that done right
at the local level there is a room for
government to do things the federal
government is what really needs to
shrink okay
okay another person wants me to go out
for a drink okay people really want me
to drink again now that I haven't been
drinking for a couple weeks
super chat been waiting to see Peter
Schiff on the show he's the most
informative capitalist I've seen in
recent years and he does talk show any
chance he'll be on you know we we had
reached out him years ago and I think
maybe it fell off the map I'd be happy
to have that conversation super chat
Dave I think you're awesome keep up the
good work thank you
you need more glamour shots can I shoot
you one day we do I need I desperately
need new glamour shots as they were or
headshots whatever you want to call them
if you are a photographer in the year in
the LA area just drop us a line on the
contact page on Ruben report comm and
let's see if we can work it out because
I didn't I never really had great photos
that I absolutely loved because I'm
always running to do a thousand things
and it seems low on the priority list
but I know it shouldn't be and
especially now with the beard now that
it doesn't seem like it's going anywhere
and people dig it and I I'm actually
digging it I do need some new shots so
let me know let's see
super chat Ken Cooley is a California
state assemblyman purple district
Christian Democrat that could be an
interesting discussion that does sound
like an interesting mix let me look into
it
super Chad I love your channel I found
you through Shapiro and have watched
just about every one of your videos you
make navigating the leftist universities
more bearable also that shirt is amazing
Rueben report comm slash store for the
shirt and thank you for that and if
you're out there in a university if
you're watching this right now just keep
fighting keep standing up for yourself
if you don't stand
up now you won't magically get braver
when you get out it ain't gonna get
easier people it ain't gonna get easier
all right let me jump back to the
patreon Phil and Crowder debate could
you make that happen well I assume you
mean Phil DeFranco and steven crowder
I'd be happy to do it again Crowder
doesn't travel that much but Crowder if
you're watching this I'll text you after
but I'd love to get you in here and if
you're talking about DeFranco I would be
happy to talk to him about that okay
though I and many others thought that
the Blair White Candice only thing was
more of a disaster than anything else I
still see the value in getting to
reasonable people together with
differing views for a discussion
moderated by you on a regular basis when
you consider doing more moderate debates
Congrats on 600,000 subscribers thanks
yeah I definitely want to do more debate
so when I'm doing this thing next week
with Shapiro and Peterson I don't know
if that's going to be a debate in a
traditional sense because I don't know
that there's you know yes Jordan
believes more Jordans a Christian and
Ben's Jew but I think their belief in
belief it's sort of similar I think they
both Jordan's probably a little more
left kind of where I've never heard
Jordan say anything politically that I
flat-out disagree with so obviously
he'll have some disagreements with Ben
but I want to talk about some some other
stuff I don't want to give too many
hints right now but I promise I'm gonna
go in a different direction than usual I
definitely want to do more debates
there's a possibility that we've got a
very cool livestream happening that
Monday on February 2nd it'll either I
think it's gonna be February 2nd or
February 5th with two people I'm trying
to work it out I don't even know if I've
told my guys yet that I'm trying to work
on this one but we shall see let's go
back to patreon
Jordan Peterson has said that most of
his followers are male would be
interesting to check stats on your
followers and then discuss the possible
reasoning especially related to
classical liberalism you know that's a
great question I don't know that we have
been cracked YouTube actually gives you
great analytics our watch times by the
way are off the charts last month our
average watch time I think was over 20
minutes which is unheard of on YouTube
where it's usually like 6 seconds or
something all our numbers are just just
exploding which is phenomenal from what
I can see on there last I saw I think we
were about 80% male 20% female now that
that's hard to really garner what that
exact
they means because YouTube in general as
far as I know skews heavily male
politics in general tends to skew male I
suspect that our 20 percent female is
probably a little disproportionately
high female but that's also just the
people I think that are signed in on
YouTube that they're getting any
information from Google so there's many
more people I get a lot of mail from
from females so I don't know that I have
anything but it's an interesting it's an
interesting piece of this that why are
so many young men sort of attracted to
these ideas and I think it does have a
lot to do with what Jordan Peterson's
talking about all the time that young
men have sort of been left behind that
they've been ignored or treated poorly
or mocked constantly and they're trying
to find some answers I think Jordans
doing a beautiful job of making it
happen
alright jump back over to super chat any
chance of an interview with Bill Maher I
love your work Dave yes
so I George Carlin if I was if I could
have anyone but Bill Maher probably at
this point is the top of people that are
living I've met him a couple times we've
had some hot and cold moments I've
talked to the producers there they
basically said I will be on the show at
some point you know for a while bill and
I agreed on so much that I think they
didn't want to bring on people that just
agree on stuff now you know where I've
shifted more to really to a libertarian
place of things and I don't want to get
lost in the classical liberal label in
libertarian all that where he definitely
still he does trade in identity politics
still right he calls the Republicans
racist all the time and all that which
is ironic because then the left uses
that on him when he talks about Islam
bill and I could have a great discussion
about what's happened to modern
liberalism so I hope I hope I'll be on
the show but everything being equal I'd
rather get him here where we could do an
hour or two and just really get into the
thick of it he's also been a huge
influence in mine I'd say about four or
five of his HBO specials are spectacular
he's done a ton of them but hopefully we
can get him here hopefully I'll be on
the show but I've also gotten to a point
where I'm kind of like I don't want a
lot you know like I used to okay I want
to be on The Tonight Show or I want to
be on real time or any of that stuff and
it's like at some point you kind of just
got to do what you do and hope that
those things come around if you do good
work Dave growing up who is your
favorite Luke Skywalker or Han Solo keep
up the great work love your show
you know when I was younger
people used to say I looked like a young
Luke my hackus my hair maybe was a
little lighter or something although I
swear to you this is all my hair and
I've never put colored it in anyway so I
think I'm more identified with Luke I
don't know that I ever felt as cool as
Han is right Han Han was the coolest I
mean even even force awakens which I
loved force awakens Han made that movie
there was something just the wit and and
and Harrison Ford I said to David this
weekend we were watching Indiana Jones
in the Temple of Doom that by the way
that opening scene in Temple of Doom
with the poison and the the lazy susan
around the table and that whole
spectacular scene what amazing
moviemaking that is that Spielberg and
his wife Kate Capshaw is the woman in it
but Harrison Ford it's like I don't know
that he's even ever been nominated for
any acting award not that that really
matters but it's like all that guy ever
did for the last 40 years make great
movies that everybody loves from Star
Wars to Indiana Jones to the fugitive to
Air Force One etc etc etc it's like that
guy is what an actor really is all about
and you don't even know that much about
him personally which is actually
refreshing because these these actors
are such pain in the ass mother
Fletcher's Oh Steve Davies is from the
Institute of Economic Affairs in London
I think I said the London X Institute of
economics okay let's see this go to
patreon for a second can you not make a
strong classical liberal case for
abortion for example individuals right
to life so this is what I got into it
Ben and look some time look II I like to
argue from fact I like to argue from law
or now you have the right what do you
have in America right you have the right
to life liberty and the pursuit of
happiness and then we have other rights
that are delineated obviously in the
Bill of Rights and local laws and things
so the right to life you have the right
to life the question is what is a life
and when they were writing that did they
mean a life that is not yet born now
what I said to Ben was for me and this
is for me and this is partly based on
emotion by the way and I admit that this
is partly based on a feeling I want the
woman to be able to control her body
up until 20 weeks there's a lot of
evidence that the fetus does not feel
anything at around 20 weeks there's
evidence that it does so to me that
would be a point where I could say all
right I'm pro-life I'm against abortion
from that point forward I'm not even
that comfortable with that but I think
you can make a sensible argument and
that's the argument I made that now
Ben's counterpoint was well look if
you're saying it's a life at 20 weeks
don't tell me it's not a life at 19 and
by the way I can't argue that point I
accept that so is there a classical
liberal argument well yeah if you're the
argument against abortion that the
conservative argument would be similar
to the classical liberal which would be
you're supposed to defend the life now
generally people on the left and
liberals are talking about the life of
the woman carrying the fetus but is
there an argument that that is a life of
course there is an argument and that's
why when I hear the real radicals on
abortion it's when they say no you can
have a late term abortion six seven nine
months nine there are people who
literally say to term that you can have
abortion meaning if you are
eight-and-a-half months pregnant there
is no doubt at that point in virtually
every case that that fetus can live
outside the womb and you're gonna be
allow that to be aborted I mean that
seems radical to me but again this is a
place where it's great to have an
interesting argument and I saw some
somebody on Twitter not on Twitter on
YouTube it came up in my suggested
videos it was something like Ben Shapiro
destroys and caps Dave Rubin on abortion
and then they just play our thing and
it's like no we disagreed so I'm good
okay people all right really Facebook
mr. Rubin what would you need to see
from the works of Iran to become a
committed Objectivist you seem to
consistently agree with their arguments
but only refer to yourself as a liberal
it's a good question now first off I've
said this before but I like doing public
events with a RI they've made it very
clear I can say whatever I want do
whatever I want I go on stage I talk
about all sorts of funny things and
silly things sometimes and all my
classical liberal beliefs and they're
they're totally cool that we are 100%
aligned as far as free speech look
you're wrong Brooke has laid out
objectivism in this very studio
extremely well I'm Rucka the youtuber
when we did YouTube week he really laid
out Colet objectivism not collectivism
really well I'll I basically like the
ideas of Objectivism I like the ideas of
rational self-interest do what is good
for you thus you will start doing what's
good for your family your community and
it starts with you and goes this way not
this way down to you I really like those
ideas I would say and that there's the
culture element to it I like the part
that it is an all coming from religion
or things that we can't prove I would
just say that at this point for me more
than anything else I just don't need
another label attached to me you know
anything like I'm always trying to clean
up the mess between liberal and
progressive or classical liberal versus
libertarian to add another word into
that mix well especially right now while
so much is being juggled all the time I
just don't see value in that
specifically but make a great argument I
know you guys love epistemology when
you're Objectivist so let me know
super chat Dave thanks for the shoutout
a s Lee is a fierce thinker and he
coined the term white left that is used
by Chinese netizens to insult leftists
you will not regret at least talking him
I promise you I will look into it for
sure you should look into getting
comedian Josh wolf on the Reuben report
not sure who that is David and add him
to the list please let's see did that
one do that one this couple here that
aren't deleted guys keep up the great
work my friend you're one of the
greatest on YouTube it's second only to
Rogen in conversation
alright I'll accept that I think some
people probably like me more some people
probably like him more I'm sure he's ok
with it and I'm okay with it too hey
Dave love your work your shows a breath
of fresh air also you should make a
shirt that says monetize this that's
actually a pretty good idea we'll look
into that huge respect from down under
mate much love from little tie big tie
news real fake news that is real don't
know what the hell you're talking about
but okay back to patreon would you still
be interested in speaking at the
University of Colorado I think Turning
Point is willing to sponsor you there
yeah I'd love to you know I went down to
Palm Beach right before Christmas and I
spoke at the turning point USA college
event and I think they said it was the
largest gathering of conservative
college students ever I went up there I
talked about being for gay marriage I
talked about being pro marijuana against
death penalty for public education etc
etc I got a freaking standing ovation
from these evil conservatives and by the
way there were gays there and there were
black people there and Muslims and
everything else they were all there and
we had a great time and Charlie Kirk who
was here last week obviously spoke there
Kandice spoke Trump jr. spoke the day
before Ben spoke there Prager Greg
Gutfeld and it was a great diverse group
of people and again I got a standing
ovation for talking about our
differences I promise you I would gladly
give that same speech if any progressive
student organization wants to invite me
and I've made that offer many times I
have yet to make it happen
Facebook what are your thoughts on the
women's March look you know if you've
got the money for a hat well it's
your right to spend it I mean what I
don't know exact I'm chump for anyone
expressing whatever their beliefs are I
don't know what these people are really
marching for women that are free in this
country period you're free to do
whatever you want they are making it
seem that Trump is coming for women or
that the government is coming for women
even I just don't know what they're
marching for it it becomes this
intersectional mess where they just love
the idea that they're being oppressed or
that they're someone's attacking their
or whatever it is I just
genuinely don't know what it is
but I do think there's a danger there
when you gin up all of this angst and
anger with people that aren't really
oppressed you know who's really
oppressed go see what's going on with
the protests in Iran where where's the
left on that talking about that women
that are really oppressed where's the
left on all of the problems in Islamic
countries with women and women that are
stuck in burkas and that although they
now are starting to be able to drive in
Saudi Arabian all that women are not
oppressed in this country are there are
there people that are bad people the
Harvey Weinstein's of the world
absolutely and should those people go
down of course they should go down but
there's something else going on here
that doesn't really make sense anymore
but their idea of protesting or you want
to get out there and put on your
out and make these you know signs that
make no sense
you know white women walking around
going I hate white feminism because I'm
such I was self flagellate in front of
all of you I bow to you all time it's so
stupid it's so stupid but how do you
really
Phil Dave all right we got about 10 more
minutes guys and then I need a 15 minute
break before I I jump on with the one
time PayPal donator Reuben report comp
slash donate if you want to do this
one-on-one with me there's also a couple
slots left on patreon group chats I
think oh man I need some water here
let's see keep up the grant we just did
that one would you be open to hosting a
debate between your own brooke and ben
shapiro on the impact of judeo-christian
values on Western society
I've loosely discussed it with both of
them I think they're in the loop on it I
suspect it will happen at some time I'd
like to do that one live maybe so stay
tuned on that we probably do it
somewhere in the LA area favorite guest
is that to mean of a question well it's
not a mean question my favorite it's
really hard to say I mean my favorite
guest look I can say this that the when
we had Sam Harris on I believe it was
September 8th 2015 the first show at or
a TV when we rebranded this into an
interview show I wasn't even intending
on doing an interview show I thought we
were gonna still do like a panel show
like we were doing at the Young Turks
and this was gonna be a one-off with Sam
that show so affected me and spelt so
real and so important and we were trying
to clean up the mess that that all of
these haters and Liars had created and
it was so intimately intertwined with
all the horrible stuff I had been seeing
on the left for so long that that to me
it was like a truly seminal moment for
me because it changed my career it
changed my thinking and I was able to
help someone at some level that I think
was so unfairly under attack so I think
that interview affected me the most but
I've been I've had some I mean some of
the interviews that I've had here I
learned every week like I know it's
weird like people don't seem to learn
week to week every day I was even
thinking this today we what we did one
of our presidents week interviews which
we're gonna put up in February five days
five different professors on five
different presidents and we did the one
about Lincoln today and I've seen the
Lincoln movie and obviously I know
enough about Lincoln but like I kept
thinking I'm learning now like I get to
learn every single day on this show
which is incredible so when I sit here
across from Eric Weinstein who I think
could possibly be the smartest man on
earth and I and Sam
eris and jordan peterson and glen beck
and praying her and Shapiro and all
these people it's like I'm able to
actually learn still so I don't is there
a favorite I don't know that I truly
don't know that there's actually a
favorite that I could specifically pick
out one one person all right I did that
already
can I be a progressive but an anti
federal central government I consider
myself progressive but I admit the
failure or a large federal government it
was like when you hear people say there
are left libertarians I don't really
understand what that means I don't think
you can be a progressed you could be for
progress meaning equality meaning true
equality under the law which by the way
we have right now we have no laws that
stop someone based on the color of their
skin or their sexuality or anything else
from getting married or taking a job or
anything like that does it mean that
there's no bigotry of course not but if
you are afraid of strong federal
government and power that gets out of
control then you cannot be a progressive
they want to make government stronger
they want to take I mean this is the
irony right now is they're screaming all
day long about Trump what is their
answer their answer is we're gonna take
guns away from you one because
progressives want to take guns away well
you hate the government but you also
want to take people's guns away there's
a logic problem there but it's also that
if you're you can't just say I hate
Trump and I'm I want big government but
well then occasionally you're gonna get
a big government guy meaning you're
gonna get a president that you don't
like in this case Trump they'd be
thrilled if Bernie was abusing executive
actions and running rampant with the
office office of the president cuz it's
there guys so you have to have
principles when it's hard to have
principles I would say scale back the
power of the federal government three
branches of government the president's
not supposed to write laws he's supposed
to sign them the judicial supposed to
make sure they're legal go to next time
you're in DC please go to the one
Memorial that's a little off the beaten
path Thomas Jefferson is you guys know
he's really my favorite founder we're
gonna one of our presidents shows is
gonna be on him go into the Jefferson
Memorial read everything that they have
they have these giant plaques with his
writings around I think there's five or
six of them read that and figure out
what this country is about and you know
I I don't see a way that you can be
progressive and and also yeah I just I
don't it just doesn't make sense to me I
just don't see it alright a couple
minutes left five minute warning people
super chat thanks Dave I'm glad I found
your channel keep up a good fight I have
no choice man what else am I gonna do
you know it's too late I want it to be
in the NBA second favorite guest I can't
I can't do it how do you stay motivated
do you get highs and lows what keeps you
consistent I'm glad you asked that night
you know I need to tell people at the
beginning we should do more personal
things like that because I'm really
happy to answer them so if we've got
anything personal now's your chance jump
in quick
I do get down no doubt about it I mean I
put a tremendous amount of energy into
this I am living this thing as you can
see I do not censor myself with you guys
you know generally the hate that I get
online doesn't really affect me it can
be annoying sometimes I mute a lot of
people like if you're just an especially
if you're just an anonymous hater and
all you're doing is getting in my
mentions to fight with people and tell
me I'm an and blah blah blah
then I just mute you and you go to the
void and whatever I just couldn't care
less about those people it's a very
special person that I block because if I
block you that means I don't want you in
my mentions at all because then you're
just there to fight with people so
you're very special if I've blocked you
but but it can't some of that can be
exhausting right and I also I would say
more than anything else I'm kind of
world weary I suppose like I genuinely
these are the issues that I care about
and that I think about constantly that I
worry about what the fate of Western
society is I worry about the direction
the country's in and that will be as
free as we are right now so that
definitely does take a toll on me what
do I do to relax I try to exercise try
to I take Emma out for a lot of walks
try to hang with some friends David's an
excellent chef check out Instagram comm
slash David's cookbook if you want to
see some of the cool things that I'm
eating or great things that I'm eating
actually I enjoy a good red wine love my
coffee try playing basketball when I can
whatever else it is now I'll be getting
back to stand up a little bit but yeah I
struggle with things just like everybody
else and you know I'm not always my best
self but I'm usually trying to be so so
there you go
super chat love your dedication to truth
and freedom Dave best wishes to you and
your husband thank
much okay will do we've got four more
minutes so I'll do two more questions
and then and then I'll do some a closing
statement
patreon do you think we could learn
something from the Jedi Sith conflict in
Star Wars - what goes on in the world is
it time for the gray Jedi to rise so the
gray Jedi for those of you that are not
to align our Jedi that sort of have both
traits of Jedi and Sith so they're a
little bit good and bad much like grey
is between black and white so there's a
little subtlety there one of the reasons
I love Star Wars is is because of that
internal fight of good and evil that we
all have the the light and the dark we
all have that at a personal level one of
the reasons that I think in retrospect
especially after seeing last Jedi which
which I'm starting to like the prequels
more in a weird way I never had a major
problems because the acting is terrible
the dialogue is terrible but the the
underlying story about power and how
someone can manipulate both sides to
build weapons and an army and an how can
have people using the political machine
against itself the good guys becoming
the bad guys all of that there's an
incredible political story in the
prequels that unfortunately I think
George Lucas probably should have had
someone else direct them because I think
that could have cleaned up the mess and
and yes Jar Jar in podracing and a
couple other things but the overarching
story about power and then when you
relate that to the good and the bad and
all of that I think it's very cool so I
think there's a lot of things that I
relate it's why I talk about Star Wars
so much you know and unfortunately mal
it'll soured on it because the last Jedi
how the hell do you not tell us who's
Snoke is Rian Johnson who the hell is
Snoke and don't tell me you're gonna
tell me in a cartoon now or you're
saving it to the next movie it's like
come on man I've accepted force Mirage
Luke already fine some other problems I
mean things should have died in both
movies I have already done this with you
guys okay two minutes left so let me
just pimp out a couple things January
31st
noon pacific ben shapiro jordan peterson
in this very studio for a couple hours
if you're in LA jordan Peterson's at the
Orpheum that night I will be there check
I'm gonna go there recall and actually
Colin Moriarty so if you
are in town come say hi to us maybe
we'll grab a drink Ruben report.com /
store if you want the classical liberal
t-shirt those of you that support us on
patreon and I go as always I give you
guys a special shout out you enable us
to do this rather weather YouTube
monetizes us or not we can still keep
going we're always trying to figure out
other ways to make this a functional and
and secure business so it's patreon.com
slash rubin report and you can you know
you can pledge $1 you can prej 500 bucks
and depending on what it is you get all
sorts of different rewards if you want
to talk to me one-on-one you want to get
in our group text chat which is actually
pretty cool I'll do that tomorrow by the
way and and whatever else there is our
goal by the end of 2018 it's ambitious
but I truly think we can do it is 1
million subscribers by the end of this
year I think we can do it this channel
has existed for about 4 years but we
didn't really start the whole time there
this channel is existed for let's say
four and a half years even I'll say five
years 600,000 subscribers that's a
little more than a hundred thousand a
year but it's really peaked in these
last two years I would think we think
that with the eleven and a half months
left and this year we can get 400,000
subscribers this year so if you dig what
we do please you know retweet us and
post it on Facebook and tell your
friends and you know we don't put we
have no budget right now for advertising
we put you know 20 bucks or something
when we do direct messages on Facebook
but we don't buy fat YouTube ads we
don't fight Twitter ads any of that kind
of stuff it's partly because the YouTube
Reb is all over the place so it's hard
to figure out what monthly budgets are
and we want to save that so we can hire
people properly and all that but you
guys are the engine that makes this
thing go I think we can get to a million
by 2018 alright I have been I have been
talking now for an hour and a half after
doing two interviews today shot a direct
message this morning Emma's looking at
me like she's got a P I thank you guys
for your support I mean 600,000
subscribers on YouTube where you know
most people are watching cat videos and
you know prank videos and people getting
hit in the nuts and all that stuff it's
like it's it's a real accomplishment and
as I said you know our watch times last
month I think it was over 20 minutes of
video that is awesome by the way if you
don't want to watch here you know we're
on Spotify now or obviously on iTunes
however you podcast you can do that
and you can get it the podcast ad-free
for five bucks a month on patreon you
can do that anyway I thank you let's
take one more sip and then give an
official goodbye all right thank you
guys have a great night everybody and oh
and tomorrow part one of my oh it's my
direct message for the week and then
part one with max lugu beer all about
food and your brain and eating right and
a little escape from politics this week
and then we're back at it next week okay
ciao